Bonjour à tous, alors c'est quelque chose
qui n'a pas pu vous échapper,
dans quelques jours s'ouvre à Paris la COP21,
la grande conférence internationale sur le changement climatique
et je me suis dit que c'était l'occasion d'essayer
de répondre à une question qu'on m'a souvent posée.
C'est assez fréquent que de la famille ou des amis
me demandent si moi, le scientifique,
je crois au réchauffement climatique.
Alors vous savez peut-être que je ne suis pas
climatologue, à la base je suis plutôt physicien
mais aujourd'hui, on va justement essayer de voir
comment on peut se faire une idée sur cette question
en utilisant le regard du physicien.
♪ [Générique] ♪
Pour commencer on va rappeler
quel est le raisonnement de base
qui est généralement tenu autour de la question
du changement climatique.
C'est un raisonnement qui tient en 3 points.
Premièrement, les activités humaines rejettent du CO2,
deuxièmement, le CO2 est un gaz à effet de serre
et troisièmement, l'effet de serre, ça réchauffe la planète.
Je voudrais qu'on examine un petit peu
en détail chacun de ces 3 points.
Vous savez peut-être que quand on brûle
un combustible qui contient du carbone
comme du bois, du pétrole, ou bien ici du propane,
on produit du dioxyde de carbone, le CO2,
qui est rejeté dans l'atmosphère.
L'atmosphère de la Terre est composée d'environ
78% d'azote, 21% d'oxygène et environ 1% d'argon.
Le CO2 là-dedans, en fait, il y en a beaucoup moins que ça
et donc on ne le mesure pas en pourcentage,
mais on le mesure en ppm,
ppm ça veut dire parties par millions,
c'est comme un pourcentage, sauf qu'au lieu d'être
un pour cent, c'est un pour un million
et donc actuellement le taux de CO2 dans l'atmosphère
est autour de 400 ppm, c'est-à-dire 0,04%.
Ça c'est la valeur aujourd'hui, mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est de regarder comment cette valeur a évolué
au cours des décennies et des siècles passés.
C'est quelque chose qu'on peut faire
parce que depuis une cinquantaine d'années
on sait mesurer directement le CO2 dans l'atmosphère
et on est capable de remonter beaucoup plus loin dans le temps
grâce à l'analyse des bulles qui sont contenues
dans des carottes de glace.
Regardons un peu ensemble l'évolution
de la concentration de CO2 dans l'atmosphère,
on va remonter jusqu'en l'an 1000.
Vous voyez qu'à cette époque et puis
pendant plusieurs siècles ensuite,
la concentration de CO2 dans l'atmosphère
est restée autour de 280 ppm,
avec quelques fluctuations, à la hausse et à la baisse.
Puis à partir des années 1850, il s'est passé un truc,
il y a eu la révolution industrielle et le taux de CO2 dans l'atmosphère
a commencé à grimper, grimper, grimper...
à tel point qu'il faut que je change l'échelle de mon graphique...
oui, en fait il faut que je la change plusieurs fois.
et voilà, le record actuel, en 2015, est juste au dessus de 400 ppm.
Bon, je crois qu'il n'y a pas besoin d'épiloguer
très longtemps sur cette courbe,
je pense que vous voyez la tendance.
Il faut être tout à fait clair sur un point, cette courbe,
on n'a absolument aucun doute dessus,
personne ne la conteste, même le plus
climato-sceptique des climato-sceptiques
est obligé de reconnaître que c'est vraiment ça
qui est en train de se passer
avec le taux de CO2 dans l'atmosphère aujourd'hui.
Ça, c'est pour le premier point.
Avant de traiter le second, je voudrais
qu'on commence par regarder le troisième,
l'idée selon laquelle l'effet de serre réchauffe la planète.
Il faut savoir que la Terre tire quasiment
toute son énergie du rayonnement solaire.
Comme la surface du soleil est à environ 5500°C,
la lumière qu'il nous envoie est principalement
de la lumière visible,
de l'ultraviolet et ce qu'on appelle de l'infrarouge proche.
la Terre va réfléchir directement une partie
de ce rayonnement, environ 30%
et elle va absorber le reste donc
c'est ça qui lui fournit son énergie.
Comme tout corps qui est chauffé à une certaine température,
la Terre va, elle aussi, émettre du rayonnement
mais comme elle est loin d'être aussi chaude que le soleil,
ce rayonnement là ne va pas être du visible ou de l'ultraviolet,
mais ce qu'on appelle de l'infrarouge lointain.
Vous savez, c'est celui qu'on peut voir
quand on met des lunettes de vision nocturne.
Alors il faut savoir que s'il n'y avait pas du tout d'effet de serre,
tout ce rayonnement infrarouge lointain
émis par la Terre repartirait dans l'espace
et il ferait environ -18°C à la surface de la Terre en moyenne.
Il n'y a pas besoin de faire de grande climatologie
pour trouver ce chiffre-là,
c'est vraiment juste deux lignes de calcul si on connaît
la physique du rayonnement thermique.
Sauf qu'on voit bien que ce n'est pas ce qui se passe sur Terre,
en réalité il ne fait pas -18°C en moyenne.
La raison c'est que ce rayonnement infrarouge lointain
qui est émis par la Terre
est fortement absorbé par les gaz de l'atmosphère
et il est réémis en partie vers la Terre.
Ça crée un flux supplémentaire
qui contribue à réchauffer la planète
et donc c'est ça qu'on appelle l'effet de serre.
Et c'est grâce à cet effet de serre qu'il ne fait pas -18°C
en moyenne sur la planète mais qu'il fait plutôt 14°C
et ça on peut le trouver en 5 - 6 lignes de calcul.
...
Donc vous voyez que l'effet de serre est un phénomène
absolument incontestable,
il n'y a absolument aucun débat sur sa réalité,
il n'y a pas besoin de grands modèles climatologiques
pour montrer qu'il y a de l'effet de serre,
c'est juste de la physique.
Et d'ailleurs, heureusement qu'il y a de l'effet de serre,
puisqu'on vient le voir,
c'est ce qui permet que la planète soit à une température
moyenne d'environ 14°C, plutôt que -18°C
et donc ça évite de vivre dans un grand désert glacé.
D'ailleurs il y a une autre illustration
bien connue de l'effet de serre,
c'est le fait, en apparence un peu paradoxal,
que la surface de Vénus
soit plus chaude en moyenne que celle de Mercure
alors que Mercure est plus proche du soleil.
Et bien c'est parce que l'atmosphère de Vénus
est composée à 96% de CO2
qui crée un effet de serre énorme.
Tout ça nous amène au second point
que je n'ai pas encore examiné,
le fait que le CO2 soit un gaz à effet de serre.
C'est vrai ça, pourquoi le CO2 et pas... l'oxygène par exemple ?
Qu'est-ce qui fait qu'un gaz donné
est un gaz à effet de serre ?
On l'a vu tout à l'heure, pour qu'il y ait effet de serre,
il faut que le rayonnement infrarouge lointain
puisse être absorbé par l'atmosphère.
Alors, sans rentrer dans les détails, pour qu'un gaz
puisse absorber les infrarouges,
il faut qu'il soit composé d'au moins 3 atomes dans sa molécule
ou alors éventuellement seulement 2 atomes
à condition que ce soit 2 atomes différents.
Bon, le CO2 a 3 atomes donc c'est un gaz à effet de serre,
l'oxygène et l'azote, et bien non, ils sont tous les deux
composés de 2 atomes identiques,
le méthane CH4, oui,
L'argon, un seul atome, donc non,
l'ozone, O3, 3 atomes, donc oui.
Et oui, l'ozone dont la couche nous protège des UV
est aussi un gaz à effet de serre
et d'ailleurs tous les gaz CFC, ceux qui
justement détruisent la couche d'ozone,
sont aussi des gaz à effet de serre.
Et puis, la vapeur d'eau, H2O,
et oui, 3 atomes donc la vapeur d'eau c'est un gaz à effet de serre
et c'est même un des plus puissants.
Alors là, vous vous demandez peut-être pourquoi
on nous em***de avec le CO2
et qu'on ne nous parle jamais de la vapeur d'eau.
C'est vrai quoi, si je me fais bouillir de l'eau pour faire un thé,
est-ce que je contribue à augmenter l'effet de serre
et à réchauffer la planète ?
Et bien non en fait, il y a une raison pour ça
et c'est vraiment important de la comprendre.
On ne peut pas durablement modifier la quantité
de vapeur d'eau contenue dans l’atmosphère
et la raison pour ça, c'est que la vapeur d'eau
de l'atmosphère est en équilibre avec les océans.
Si on essaye d'augmenter artificiellement
la concentration en vapeur d'eau dans l'atmosphère,
par exemple on se met tous à se faire des thés
et à prendre de grandes douches chaudes tous ensemble
et bien en quelques jours, l'océan aura absorbé tout le surplus
et la concentration de vapeur d'eau dans l'atmosphère
sera revenue à sa valeur normale.
Donc oui, c'est vrai, la vapeur d'eau est
un des plus importants gaz à effet de serre
mais on ne peut pas durablement
modifier sa concentration dans l'atmosphère
contrairement au CO2 qui lui, on l'a vu,
s'accumule dangereusement.
Donc si on revient sur nos trois points, vous voyez
qu'il n'y a absolument aucun doute
et aucun débat sur le mécanisme du réchauffement climatique,
ce n'est même pas de la climatologie,
c'est vraiment juste de la physique
et ce n'est même pas de la physique super compliquée.
Là, j'espère vous avoir convaincus
que le raisonnement est absolument incontestable.
Sauf...
Sauf que sur des questions aussi sérieuses que ça,
on ne peut pas se contenter d'un raisonnement qualitatif.
Ok, le mécanisme est là, ça c'est clair,
mais en chiffres, ça fait combien ?
♪ [Générique] ♪
On a vu tout à l'heure que le taux de CO2
dans l'atmosphère était d'environ 280 ppm
avant la révolution industrielle.
Depuis il a augmenté de quasiment 50%.
Ce CO2 supplémentaire qui a été balancé
dans l'atmosphère depuis la révolution industrielle
provoque un effet de serre plus gros
que ce qu'il devrait être naturellement
et pour quantifier ça, on va essayer de mettre ça
sous la forme d'un surplus de rayonnement
qui est dû à cet effet de serre additionnel.
Avant de parler du surplus de rayonnement, on va voir
ce que le soleil nous envoie déjà à la base.
Si vous vous mettez juste au-dessus de l'atmosphère
et que vous vous tournez vers le soleil, bien de face,
vous allez recevoir un flux d'environ
1366 watts par mètre carré (W/m²),
c'est la valeur maximum, sauf qu'il y a
deux choses à prendre en compte.
La première, c'est qu'un endroit donné de la Terre
ne va pas être en permanence juste face au soleil,
son orientation va changer et en plus, en moyenne,
il sera la moitié du temps dans la nuit.
Donc la puissance moyenne qui va
effectivement être reçue sur chaque m² de la Terre,
c'est seulement un quart de la valeur maximale.
La deuxième chose qu'il faut considérer c'est que, on l'a dit,
la Terre va réfléchir directement environ 30% de ce rayonnement,
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'albédo.
Au total si on fait le calcul, on trouve que la Terre
reçoit un flux solaire moyen d'environ 240 W/m².
L'effet du CO2 qui a été accumulé dans l'atmosphère
par rapport au niveau qu'il avait avant la révolution industrielle
équivaut à un surplus de rayonnement d'environ 2 W/m²
et si on ajoute les autres gaz à effet de serre,
le total est à peu près de 3 W/m².
Ce surplus de rayonnement, on appelle ça le forçage radiatif.
Un forçage radiatif de 3 W/m², ça veut dire
que c'est comme si le soleil,
au lieu de nous balancer 240 W/m², il nous en balançait 243.
En gros, c'est comme si le soleil brillait 1% plus fort.
Alors ça ne paraît pas grand-chose mais
c'est quand même ça qui menace de tout changer.
J'en profite pour faire une petite parenthèse.
Il y a un argument climato-sceptique classique qui dit
que le réchauffement qu'on observe actuellement
ne serait pas dû aux gaz à effet de serre émis par l'homme
mais il serait dû aux variations naturelles
de la puissance du soleil.
C'est vrai, la puissance que le soleil émet
varie naturellement selon des cycles
et on peut même la mesurer.
Vous voyez la courbe ici et en fait derrière
le chiffre moyen d'environ 1366 W/m²
que je vous donnait tout à l'heure,
se cache en fait des variation de plus ou moins
0,5 W/m² selon un cycle qui dure onze ans.
Ça c'est pour la puissance maximale, une fois
qu'on a pris en compte la division par 4
et l'albédo de 30%,
il reste moins de 0,1 W/m² de variation au niveau du sol.
Donc le forçage radiatif dû aux cycles solaires est de 0.1 W/m²
et on a vu que le forçage radiatif dû aux gaz à effet de serre
émis par l'homme depuis la révolution industrielle est de 3 W/m².
Donc voilà, il n'y a pas de comparaison.
♪ [Générique] ♪
Donc on a vu que l'effet des gaz à effet de serre
qui ont été émis par l'homme depuis la révolution industrielle
équivaut à un forçage radiatif d'environ 3 W/m².
Maintenant la question est, quel impact ça va avoir
sur la température moyenne à la surface de la Terre ?
Si on ajoute ces 3 W/m² dans notre modèle
tout simple qui tient en quelques lignes,
on trouve que cet effet de serre supplémentaire
provoque une hausse
d'environ 1°C de la température à la surface de la Terre.
Bon, dit comme ça, ça ne parait pas grand-chose 1°C.
Oui, sauf que ça c'est pour les valeurs actuelles
de concentration des gaz à effet de serre,
si on continue à en rejeter comme si de rien n'était,
évidemment ça va augmenter.
Et puis, il y a un autre facteur à prendre en compte,
c'est la vapeur d'eau.
Alors oui, je vous ai dit tout à l'heure, la vapeur d'eau
c'est le plus important des gaz à effet de serre
sauf qu'on ne peut pas modifier sa concentration dans l'atmosphère.
Sauf qu'il y a un truc qui permet de modifier sa concentration,
c'est si on augmente la température
puisque je vous ai dit, le fait que la concentration
de vapeur d'eau dans l'atmosphère soit stabilisée
est lié à son interaction avec l'océan.
Sauf que vous savez peut-être que l'air chaud
peut contenir plus d'humidité que l'air froid
et donc, si la planète se réchauffe, il va pouvoir
y avoir plus de vapeur d'eau dans l'atmosphère.
Donc si la température augmente à cause
de l'effet de serre dû au CO2,
l'atmosphère va pouvoir stocker plus de vapeur d'eau,
qui va provoquer plus d'effet de serre,
ce qui va encore accroître le réchauffement.
Ce qu'on a là, c'est ce qu'on appelle une rétroaction positive.
Alors on dit rétroaction positive parce que
le phénomène se renforce lui-même,
il s'auto aggrave.
Evidemment, pour nous, ce n'est pas positif du tout.
Des rétroactions positives de ce genre là, il y en a d'autres.
Par exemple, si la banquise se met à fondre,
la Terre va réfléchir moins de rayonnement solaire,
donc va en absorber plus, ce qui va contribuer
encore à aggraver son cas.
Ces rétroactions positives, on pourrait imaginer
qu'elles conduisent à un phénomène d'emballement
ou le réchauffement s'entretient lui-même
et la Terre se réchauffe de plus en plus.
On pense que c'est ce qui s'est d'ailleurs passé sur Vénus.
Heureusement, les spécialistes estiment que
c'est peu probable que cela se produise pour nous.
Une des choses qui nous fait dire ça,
c'est qu'il y a des centaines de millions d'années,
l'atmosphère de la Terre contenait 5 à 10 fois plus
de CO2 que ce qu'elle a aujourd'hui
et les températures étaient vraisemblablement
supérieures d'au moins 5°C
et pourtant la planète s'en est remise.
Ça veut dire qu'en plus des rétroactions positives,
il existe aussi des rétroactions négatives,
c'est-à-dire des mécanismes qui viennent freiner
et contrebalancer le phénomène d'effet de serre.
Il y a par exemple les nuages, on sait que
si la concentration en vapeur d'eau augmente,
la quantité de nuages peut augmenter,
ce qui contribue à renvoyer une partie du rayonnement
solaire et donc à modérer le réchauffement.
Sauf qu'estimer la contribution exacte
de ces rétroactions négatives est assez difficile
et la meilleure manière qu'on ait de le faire,
c'est de faire des modèles très détaillés
qui prennent en compte l'atmosphère, les océans,
les courants, etc... et de simuler tout ça.
C'est ce qu'on appelle un modèle de circulation générale.
Alors oui c'est vrai, quand on utilise ces modèles,
il y a des incertitudes,
c'est lié notamment au fait que tous les modèles
ne prennent pas en compte de la même manière
les effets de ces rétroactions positives et négatives
et du coup quand on simule une situation donnée
avec tous les modèles,
ils ne donnent pas les mêmes augmentations de température.
Ce que vous voyez ici, par exemple,
c'est un scénario donné d’émissions
et chaque ligne bleue représente la prédiction d'un modèle,
il y a 42 modèles et donc ils font tous une prédiction différente
et il y a une incertitude sur l'élévation de température à la fin.
Ça, ça vient des rapports du GIEC donc,
contrairement à ce qu'on entend parfois,
les résultats du GIEC sont totalement transparents sur le fait
qu'il existe des incertitudes de modélisation.
Mais franchement, vous trouvez que ça change le message ?
En gros, on a un phénomène qui, je le répète,
sur le plan physique est absolument incontestable.
Les humains émettent du CO2, le CO2 est un gaz
à effet de serre, l'effet de serre réchauffe la planète.
Les seules choses qui restent en suspens,
c'est de savoir si, avec un peu de chance,
les rétroactions négatives ne vont pas être un petit peu
plus bénéfiques que ce qu'on s'imaginait avant.
On va prendre une analogie: vous voulez sauter
par la fenêtre du 6ème étage.
La physique de base est assez claire sur ce qui va se passer,
vous allez tomber et puis au niveau du sol,
vous allez vous écraser.
Sauf que...
il y a quelques incertitudes parce que ça se trouve,
si vous sautez du 6ème,
au 5ème il y a un balcon un petit peu plus long
qui va vous rattraper
ou bien une fois arrivé au niveau du sol,
en fait il y a un gros tas de poubelles
et vous allez atterrir sur le tas de poubelles qui va
freiner votre chute et vous allez vous en tirer.
Donc oui, il y a quelques incertitudes, hein...
Mais ce n'est quand même pas sûr.
Du coup, vous faites quoi, vous sautez quand même ?
J'espère que mon message est clair.
Oui c'est vrai, il y a des incertitudes sur l'augmentation
de température exacte qu'on va avoir
du fait de tous les gaz à effet de serre
qu'on rejette dans l'atmosphère.
Ce que vous voyez là, par exemple, c'est les simulations du GIEC
pour le scénario où essentiellement
on se tourne les pouces et on ne fait rien,
vous voyez la courbe moyenne et vous voyez
les incertitudes liées aux modèles.
Donc, il subsiste un doute pour savoir si, en 2100,
on sera effectivement à 3°C de plus parce que
les rétroactions négatives auront été plutôt favorables
ou bien au contraire on sera à 5°C de plus.
Alors on sera probablement quelque part entre les deux
mais ce n'est pas parce qu'il subsiste des incertitudes
qu'il ne faut rien faire, c'était le sens
de mon analogie du saut par la fenêtre.
Vous savez, on parle souvent de sauver la planète,
mais en fait ce n'est pas vrai,
la planète elle s'en fout, la planète elle va s'en remettre,
je vous ai dit, il y a déjà eu des périodes de l'histoire de la Terre
où il y avait 5 fois plus de CO2 et où il faisait 5°C de plus
et la Terre s'en est très bien tirée.
D'ailleurs c'était même des époques assez sympas,
par exemple c'était le cas au jurassique,
vous savez, l'époque où il y avait notamment les dinosaures.
Non, la Terre elle va s'en remettre, hein...
Si le changement climatique dont on parle
aujourd'hui se produit réellement,
il y a une espèce qui va morfler surtout... c'est nous, voilà.
Bon enfin, je ne vais pas vous faire la leçon,
je pense que vous la connaissez,
il faut qu'on fasse tous des efforts
pour essayer de consommer moins d'énergie
et en particulier moins d'énergies fossiles
mais quand même, ce n'est pas sûr que ça suffise.
Je pense que la science et la technologie
vont aussi avoir leur rôle à jouer la-dedans
et en tant que vulgarisateur scientifique, c'est un peu
là-dessus que j'avais envie de finir.
Je crois qu'il faut aussi que les sociétés
dans lesquelles on vit fassent des efforts collectifs
pour essayer d'encourager la recherche scientifique
qui permettra peut-être de produire des technologies
pour consommer moins d'énergie
ou alors produire de l'énergie plus propre,
je ne sais pas moi, des panneaux photovoltaïques
qui seraient plus efficaces et moins chers
ou bien quelque chose autour de l'hydrogène
ou de la fusion nucléaire, moi je n'en sais rien...
Mais en tout cas, ce qui est sûr,
c'est que ça ne va pas s'inventer tout seul.
Bref, prenez le vélo, prenez les transports en commun,
mais n'oubliez pas aussi, je ne sais pas moi,
d'écrire à votre député
pour lui dire de soutenir la recherche en sciences et en technologie
parce que c'est aussi une des clés du problème.
Merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo.
Comme d'habitude, n'hésitez pas à la partager,
surtout si vous avez des amis qui ne croient
pas vraiment au réchauffement climatique.
Comme d'habitude vous pouvez me retrouver
sur les réseaux sociaux Facebook et Twitter,
c'est les meilleurs endroits pour avoir des infos sur la chaîne.
Ceux qui le souhaitent peuvent me soutenir sur Tipeee,
merci infiniment à tous les tipeurs qui me soutiennent
et puis vous pouvez aussi me retrouver
sur mon blog qui s'appelle Science Etonnante.
Merci, à bientôt !